I'm just gonna yeah I just um you did
the mic but we're still eating
anyway I'm back here with Rudy rent him
out he just did his three-hour stream of
the game because he had to come in for
somebody else
which is actually yeah I see that as an
absolute win now
I'm gonna need to somehow and catch up
to what he's done I've been watching
some of the stream but it just looks way
too good I have no idea how I can even
measure up to what he's done and I'll
shove it up in a second for some of the
people who haven't seen it really cool
and the idea of our streams is basically
that I'm going to continue his park and
then possibly after me Paso is going to
continue the park as well so we we can
really develop this into a full-grown
custom zoo of our own which you usually
don't see on these streams because yeah
basically they reset the park after
every stream for every streamer but
since we know each other and we want to
see what we can do with this we're gonna
continue the park
yeah I'm still not done I'm eating my
final bite here no I can probably turn
on the camera right now
I was this transitioning all right I
mean let's finish up our meal here I
have not lunch what time is it even oh
yes here's the park and there are some
stuff missing here there's a there's a
big gaping hole where there used to be
some enclosures and shops
well I say enclosures but they were
really unfinished and here's
british-built
I'm going to do this here we go so
really built a giant indoor area for the
lemurs and it's absolutely amazing it's
something that I'm really excited to see
because no one else has really tried it
yet on this view I've heard that best in
slot tried something similar but just
this whole glass dome with an entire
biome inside it is something that we
haven't really seen yet and it looks
it's already looking absolutely amazing
I really love it to have a kind of
jungle biome in here with the lemurs in
it and the guests can freely walk around
and interact with the animals and there
are even climbing elements which really
built completely all by himself just by
putting different logs and different
pieces together and the lemurs will
actually climb on these and use them to
interact with the guests as well so that
is really cool you can just see them
walking on the paths here
and the lemurs seem to be enjoying it as
well
the guests definitely like it but the
lemurs doing as we can see here we have
some giant tortoises in here as well
oh they're starving right well let's see
nourishment requires a keeper yeah I'm
just gonna put in a few extra keepers
then perhaps they didn't refill the food
on time I see
I don't know this that's an including
enrichment items oh we can only but yeah
it seems like everything is going fine
so far and yeah this is definitely the
coolest bill that I've seen in all of
the streams it's really awesome
most of the streams have just been
playing through the game and trying to
discover what's in there but really
trying to see how you can build stuff
it's really cool so I'm gonna try to do
my best to measure up to this as well
but I have no idea how successful that
is going to be I couldn't give you a bit
of a spoiler
I'm sure they'll be fine I can give you
a bit of a spoiler if we go to the
animal training center here I should
yeah these guys have all in there
oh I don't see I did purchase them oh
yeah hopefully we'll get that back
anyway I was I was planning to build a
Bengal tiger exhibit and the tiger but
hopefully we could just build it and
then hopefully by the time we are
somewhat done there will be some Tigers
in the training center as well because
you're pretty much at the mercy of the
training centre depending on what
animals are available in other zoos or
rescued from the wild or breeding
programs etc set something to keep in
mind as well so yeah I do want to build
something with buildings especially
given that Rudy has continued this very
cool looking symmetrical well
symmetrical layout of the park with the
entrance building very classical and the
train station and finally the giant
glass dome so I wouldn't like to
continue something like that but I have
to say I haven't really played around
with the building elements that much
I've given them a quick overview before
but everything that I'm gonna do here is
this gonna be completely on this pond so
just just as a warning this is probably
not gonna be that good but still have a
quick look and all of these items and
see what would be best to use here a lot
of this is very much limited to the to
the classical English sense of the
machinery type but this map starts out
with which in the final beta I'm quite
sure there will be much more scenery
available but this is really just
limited to what's in this scenario in
this build right now
I'm not collectively to going to be
doing too many spires here so that's a
really quiet yeah yeah technically you
could make a floating island floating
zoo where every exhibit is a separate
yeah Pandora's in worship say I do oh
and then you have like lines connecting
them and only the animals can climb it
oh it's taken we have so many messages
so there might be something really wrong
we know that's wait these guys have
escaped when did that happen and maybe
just to extinct and some of the rocks
are hanging so as soon as they climb
over the rocks the game things they
escape but technically they're not yeah
yeah I don't mind it too much but
basically the issue area is over here
yeah there's this enclosure wall which
sticks out from the actual wall but then
the lemurs can actually climb on here
and rests over here which as you can see
they're doing
I never mind we're gonna need to build
some race for these guys what's going
wrong here actually got some things I
think we might just
right yeah so one of the ostriches is
actually injured so yeah but I still
wanna I still want to check it out there
they're already in advance that's fine
but I do want to check on the lemurs
because the fact that we have two dead
lemurs flying around just in a dome
that's not sleeping on the rocks you
don't get to see which are deceased it
seems like the most of them are honestly
could be yeah actually that might very
well be I'm not entirely sure because if
none of the other well their nutrition
oh right okay is that something yeah
they're climbing on the vines that's
really cool I'm trying to click you can
you stop moving
[Music]
[Music]
I could try maybe putting in a different
food enrichment items see enrichment
items
really how do you clean windows at the
top of the bill okay that's something to
look into in a second here's the ring
yeah you're right I'm just gonna put
some more slow feeders and we'll see if
that makes difference probably not yeah
they'll definitely not be able to eat
anything from that or that I guess this
low-pressure is the only thing that
could possibly work I'm just gonna put
it in there so does the glass really get
dirty because it seems to be doing all
right
I don't think anything on these textures
really seems to change the rain cleans
them that would be awesome yeah I think
I think you don't have to look after
building parts although I know that I
also have to say that would be a bit too
much of a good thing
yeah I'm not gonna build grace for these
guys I'm sorry there are some other
things that I yeah exactly so my idea
was and I'd be really happy to get some
feedback on this is why
do we have any animals in this room oh
yeah anyway my idea was to build an
exhibit with a kind of a thematic style
to it and I was thinking about going for
the Tigers and building something
related to their to their culture and
nature of where they're from
unfortunately they're mostly from the
Indian subcontinent generally and we
don't really have many scenery pieces
that could fit for that look I think so
that would be quite a struggle that said
I had this idea to build something like
the Hanging Gardens of Babylon and use
that to hide away their shelters and
also the backstage buildings for the
stock for to take care of the Tigers and
I think it could be set up in such a way
that it could also slightly cover the
train tracks and just basically be this
large thematic scenery piece at the end
of this this straight area coming from
the entrance and I'm not sure what you
guys think of that I'd be very down to
have some constructive criticism and
feedback and ideas I think it would be
really hard yeah considering the pieces
but I think it would be possible
honestly I'm just gonna have to look
through some of the pieces that we have
yeah see what's recoverable and see what
we can work with wall decorations yeah
as you can see everything is quite
limited
but I think with these kinds of pieces
the Hanging Gardens of Babylon have kind
of a classical style to them yeah and I
think with pieces like this you could
definitely build all kinds of booths
rims decorations pillars will definitely
be an issue here whoo and these are some
of these are great pieces and some of
them aren't but you can think you can
yeah quite easily actually stack them
into each other and use them to create
different kinds of shapes depending on
what you want to go for actually that's
that's Evite's
no that's fine that's actually quite
awesome use the red colored roof parts
and maybe bamboo that's cetera yeah that
sounds good
all right so I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna take some time for myself well not
really for myself because I'm streaming
but I'm just gonna take some time to
look at the available pieces kind of
consider what we can build things out of
what's possible architecture
that's brick pillars might be useful can
you recover these that's the question
now they are basically just recommend
bridge and these same here so this would
be quite White's but I think it would be
doable for the pillars and then finally
I've seen posts um who and we have
different wooden planks as well that's
good you can make a Chinese base some
enclosure
with the Bengal tiger possibly I guess
but at the same time I think yeah
something like the Bhutan or its event
area would actually be really cool
that's true I'm just not sure if I can
do that these senior pieces I really
like these textures but we don't really
have a smaller pillar to work with when
it comes to these but I think I do think
these could work very well okay so I'm
just gonna put a stone here and see what
different pieces actually work with this
so these pillars quite white I think it
could work
which pieces lots of different
decoration pieces for that that might
actually work
yeah are there actually any recallable
pieces in the game yet there are
definitely some and I don't know how
many of these pieces will become a
recolor more if they're gonna say as
they are but recolor ability is
definitely thing and I've noticed that a
lot of the smaller pieces or single
scenery items are definitely recordable
so we'll come across some of those at
some point for sure with the other
decorations at some points
oh no wait it's in ruins I think
actually no that's not it either more
decorations there we go so yeah this is
quite right but it'll do
hold on what is that what is that
placement oh that's really cool oh so
it's yeah I they on the outside and
inside that's really useful all right I
don't think we've we've seen decoration
pieces and planet goes to do this
this one doesn't have a grit yeah this
one doesn't snap to it
and this one does maybe I don't know
just fooling around right now do
something like that actually that
doesn't look too great
like so
he's underneath it I really like that
you can add a lot of current variety
with these different pieces yeah like
what a snap to it yeah because I was
looking for something like this you
could easily just make it yourself yeah
and then copy around any other textures
definitely look amazing even add some
decorations like these in there some of
these could be placed on top of that as
well we'll see how that works I think
actually they're slightly more narrow
one or sinking it
yeah something like that we could stop
playing with that and then we also have
the balustrade which I think I'm gonna
want to have on pretty much every floor
it was responding but there we go that's
a really good point because I just
another one of the turtles is starving
yeah just gonna quickly check that out
before I go back into the building yeah
so what's with the nutrition yeah but
you need the keepers to actually put the
food in there right so we can at least
we can easily fix that right I don't
know where my thing has appeared
yeah I don't know how far the turtles
can really reach anything I'll be quite
up here just to save the turtles real
quick yeah yeah I think that should just
about do it I'm just gonna add a small
one somewhere just in case yeah yeah I
would love to do a Chinese or kind of
like Himalayan yeah or two that's kind
of look but I I think that's out of the
question with these pieces but I think
something Babylonian is decently doable
although I have to say I still need to
like these pieces put together quite
well know if you have the ballast trades
on it yeah I think that'll really work
but I'm not quite sure about the the
pillars it's still gonna be quite
difficult so just in case yeah I'm just
gonna see to what extent the colours of
the pillars really fit into the other
pieces
what pillar what color pillars did they
use for these I'm pretty sure yeah
that's the same piece this isn't it
limestone pillar base limestone oh and
they have caps as well I didn't know
that because really that's that's
something that I kind of feel this
building is missing of course you find
buildings without
this bikini architecture what every way
yeah I think I'm just gonna use the same
columns or oh this one looks it's like
these good it looks like the dog and I
think that I'll be able to carry the
weight of all Hanging Gardens because
they'll be like white heavy and I think
I'm gonna go with this one however there
might be some planters somewhere in the
game that could work with that so here
we have a cat that can four square
pillars and then we have the base I
could probably use these bases and ooh
those are quite large actually but yeah
those are not the best I'm gonna go into
I don't know exactly where it is
centerpieces might have some other
things that might work you could use
that as a basic that's that's quite
Dorothy yeah it's not too many pieces in
here so I think it'll be difficult but
what you definitely can do is do that
thing where you have vases with glasses
on top yeah illustrates I'm just looking
for one little piece that could maybe
fit in a little bit better let me just
copy this over so we can have a bit of a
look of how this would work in the end
I'll just experimenting with what pieces
can work together here before I start
the building actual real thing what is
this volume button work I don't know
maybe just I'm slightly moving the
volume button can anybody tell if my
voice is getting slightly louder that
would be amazing
yeah he's been watching the whole time
in general yeah yeah they're absolutely
amazing these are quite big actually I
would have liked the scene slightly
smaller elements I'm just gonna keep
searching and see if there's anything
else that we can use here yeah I think
that just to be very sensitive to us
because it's so loud it doesn't really
change too much because you guys would
then only hear them and cheering over
there
yeah that's also true they're definitely
making a lot of noise behind us as well
if you're very cheeky you could build
that into yeah you do see small being
underneath kind of words could do or
something like that yeah that's
definitely too big but it's cool to have
all of these funds and elements
yeah sorry frontier we're already using
pieces in ways that they're not supposed
to be used okay all right thank you this
one is slightly no it's just about the
same size as that piece actually you
take that and then combine it with
colors underneath here that might
actually work you can find that with
this
that's a good go for that
yeah all right okay so let's get rid of
this whole shebang and start building an
actual enclosure so then what I also
want to try is in a lot of real shoes
you'll see something of a ditch around
the perimeter of the habitat yeah so you
won't really have a big fence and I
would like to try something like that
and see if it's doable at all so Mike
yeah yeah that is true so it has to be I
think so the way that I think it would
make sense is to have an empty date yeah
but then then it would make a very tall
wall so for the yes side you'll have a
very low fence yeah but then on the
other side of the title it will be very
yeah very tall might even need an anti
climbing thing on that but I'm pretty
sure that's that won't be too necessary
though I think Bengal tigers can
probably climb a bit better
and also if anybody if anybody really
has an urgent comments that they want me
to consider just shout it out in the
comments and I'll get to it there are
also still some requests that people
gave to me on this cord and Twitter that
I might want to get to I'd love to have
some some of around sort of shape around
here where you see and then a ditch and
then sort of an island with the gardens
behind it the train going over all right
so if you want to use here I don't think
I want to switch up the past I think I'm
just gonna keep going with this but it
might be cool to see do we have
different parts in the park not really
right there's there definitely some
different parts with all the main points
of the same texture I kind of think
that's a shame actually I would always
like to differentiate a bit between
different areas with the panting
students so perhaps yeah and some of the
later updates I think we saw that quite
a bit in Plymouth coaster as well we
started off with a very limited amount
of part thanks to remove some of these
parts and make this a bit wider because
I want to have too much of a circular
shape to this
and I need to keep track of the time as
well because I basically only have an
hour and a half right oh no surely we
don't actually I didn't notice that
there was terraforming on here but we
have a small hill going and I wanted to
be flats I'm definitely going to
terraform in this whole area but I
wanted to be plan for the time being so
okay actually starts looking really bad
I'm gonna need to consider how this
transitions into other areas if anything
I should probably actually race this a
bit and then have a slight transition
into this area yes
so the enclosure could be over here
you should try and check the training
center periodically that's a really good
point let's see if we have any Tigers at
the moment but I haven't checked it in a
long time in areas so we could but no
nevermind
but I think it makes sense that like
some of the the charismatic big animals
are lacking usually from the animal
training center because they'll be much
rarer to get as a zoo as well in real
life charismatic megafauna team
[Music]
so people kept asking at my streams
online already I just figured that
YouTube has some serious missions at the
moment processing has been it was quite
long person might arrive minutes
so yeah there's quite a wide path
because I'm expecting Tigers to be quite
a popular exhibit at the zoo
have you heard anything about ideas for
future DLCs or anything nope we honestly
don't have a clue about that actually
that's actually I have to say for this
demo bill is demo Bell specifically the
terrain tools are still a bit laggy so
if you guys noticed that that's
something that has to do with this build
specifically and should be patched out
once the beta comes out it's not
actually breeding and birth mechanics or
does it just like happen there are some
mechanics for sure yeah but I think
usually if you just put males and
females together they eventually usually
just get it on and you start getting
babies and you need to give them
contraceptives to prevent this from
happening if you don't want to want to
have them having babies but apparently
the contraceptives those work in this
bill tighter so we still have
that's
all of this I don't have this that looks
oh I'm not really really happy with that
we need to smooth that out quite a bit
more do you know any animals that will
be in the game that haven't been
announced I I don't think we're allowed
to comment on that
sometimes would be less because you guys
get the info from everywhere exactly we
were like all of a sudden wait there is
this and this and I was like yeah we're
missing out on some of the announcement
ourselves definitely but in any case we
definitely know some things that we're
not allowed to say but generally
speaking we don't know much should say
that catch that is not going to be 88
approved for wheelchair people but I'm
just gonna go forward with it I'm sorry
everybody who's seen a wheelchair I
swear I tried to make this Zoo inclusive
but I just have don't have the time to
bother okay I want to get this I think
that should be able to make this
yeah that's oh that's just the trick
from the planet coast is that I'm not
sure this is a feature but I'm sure this
is the kind of thing that they didn't
think about then in hindsight they were
like oh yeah that's that's a future I do
want this to be bits and then I do need
to cook up some of the other parts as
well
yeah this enclosure itself is not going
to be the most beautiful thing in the
world but I'm trying my best within the
given time limit that I have and just I
mean this is gonna be my first actual
proper enclosure in the games yeah in in
advance I already apologize if this
doesn't turn out to be much good yeah
yeah I'm just gonna lay out the general
terrain of the habitat and then I'll
start earning a building once that's
done right although I think it should be
good to not be just the simple enclosure
fence then yeah so the ditch isn't
looking too great because it's
completely unsmooth but the idea is that
I'll be covering up all of that with
some kind of warm
and in a perfect world where I had a lot
of time I would have actually loved to
make like some smaller parts as well
they yeah and at the end around here
where you can go up a bit and have a
specific viewing area but in this case
I'm just gonna keep it quite general
like a path around it yah was also
interesting when I was in the Prague zoo
they had actually an exhibit very
similar like this for the Lions which is
quite round and really just had a glass
wall with a ditch in front of it
but what's also interesting is that the
glass has these little dots on them
prevent birds from playing I kind of
messed up on oops
kind of messed up on the terraforming
over here but it's it's a quick build
I'm sorry I'm gonna cut some corners
here and there so let's see if we can
fit a habitat wall on top of this Juelz
one of the people helping out here and
of course a longtime member of the
planet goes the community and it just
passed by here in full lion costume well
not a costume but face paint but yeah
I'm really good yeah actually it's a
good idea probably to make it
to try to try and see how we can make
this transition so I'm gonna I don't
know what chain-link be enough or do I
really need electric fences well I could
also go with something stone or
something but I'm just gonna try an
electric just to be on the safe side I
definitely don't want my in to escaping
anytime soon
good always adjust that at some point in
future and oh yeah of course it's a rain
so I can't just easily clip into that
but all you can actually do it that way
it's fine yeah and then put a different
wall on top of it right yeah yeah but I
think if I just do it with the habitats
outline like this although then you
might get the thing where it gives you
the message that they've escaped so I'm
gonna try to keep this as close to the
edge as possible and then just pretended
I'll build some wall over it at some
point maybe next year I'll just move the
terrain in there oh yeah that's true
yeah I think I'll have a bit of an
overhang anymore or something you know
you could even have an overhang of the
ditch and gives people a real viewing
platform oh yeah good point
yeah I remember that as well because
that was one of the the first screen
shots that kind of teased the idea yeah
habits that outlines rather than just
simple barriers everywhere wait I've
been bullying an electric fence the
whole time never mind I'm just gonna say
[ __ ] that with that yeah and then at
some point it was gonna have to go
behind buildings and I'm gonna hide the
rest of the fence inside
in here somewhere that could be in a
bleed or some sort of entrance and this
is all going to be covered by the
building eventually hopefully if all
goes right because I'm under a pretty
strict time constraints okay yeah sure
you can already connect that so there's
gonna be the size of the habitat I think
that's very fair
see if we can already trade some Bengal
lions because that would be yeah yeah
tiger's eye nice so yeah and then you
can trade center right yeah there we go
now I don't think we'll have another
Bengal tiger already but I'm just gonna
check just in case I like to reconsider
water that's a good point
I'm gonna I'm gonna work on bats that's
a really good point
oops so I'm gonna have to edit all of
these barriers here so at least the one
that goes into the water here I'm gonna
change that into stone and actually over
here I should probably do the same
because this on the side of the path so
it's really on the other bank that I
don't need a fancy fence that was not on
purpose I swear
what's this so I need to change all of
these into habit and outlines I also
just want to quickly shout out again
that in the final bill you'll be able to
drag this whole thing and create and
switch between different pen styles at
once but in this bill it's not working
yet so that's why I'm doing these all
separately but in the final bill that
should be a lot easier
to do this exactly does the fence type
work into gameplay that's actually it's
something yes yeah that's does it
yeah sure because if you have like oh
yeah oh yeah good point
energy is sucking energy glass isn't
yeah but glass is getting dirty wild
stone isn't so there are quite a few
things that you have yes and some of
them they can climb over and someday
some of them they can't so the lemurs
for instance have a wooden barrier that
they can climb over which has an anti
climbing device on top of it but then
they also have concrete barriers or now
they're the glass barriers which are at
least smooth so then you don't need an
offer but you have to make it light
enough that I can jump it yeah it's a
really really good mechanic good so yeah
we could actually add some water in here
because I think being vengal Tigers they
do like swimming and then I need to find
some way to make this into a
decent-looking wall and we'll see how
that works
ooh but something to keep in mind I
think you can terraforming whatever from
while there's already water again yeah
so that's something to do with the
volumetric water so yeah that's
different from planet coaster where you
can just keep building but because it's
a trade-off but it's definitely a good
yeah it's worth it I think so I'm just
gonna make this a bit larger
so I'm gonna have to smooth these smooth
the heck out of this before the waters
in there it's otherwise it's gonna look
a bit weird
you wave that silver set in their booth
we're kind of in a hurry well I hope I
waved back actually because I always
find a way back at people just in case
but there are a lot of people right in
front of us passing by so sometimes it's
it's difficult to keep track
yeah let's actually smooth that out a
bit
certain defenses might last longer yeah
that's also a really good point
especially if you have strong animals
that you don't want escaping you
definitely it seems like you really need
to use the stronger defenses which makes
it quicker
yep so you always need some mechanics to
keep track of how things are going
Who am I really gonna have to repaint
some of that at some points but they
can't raise to rename that no no no
although this is an easy way to build
structure like that I suppose yeah I
think if you want to have a slight hill
in the middle actually so yeah yeah
exactly likely to just keep that and I'm
just gonna build a bit into this
yeah it looks like that should be fine
it's not going to be the best
terraforming ever but yeah again we're
on the limited time schedule here yeah
and I really hope they stay in the
habitat I'm very curious to see if this
actually works if having this wall here
is going to keep the Tigers inside the
habitat so now I want to build some kind
of wall section and I'm not sure what
the pieces would be best for that but I
think actually I want to use the dry
stone walls I did the drawing stone
walls or some kind of log piece I think
actually the log piece would make more
sense of the problem and then if we have
that overhanging the terrain enough that
should be fine I'm actually very curious
to see if we can do this in a similar
way to planet coaster so just gonna
build it like this and then put a fence
on top of it for the guests some kind of
decoration do we have fence pieces that
are not actual fences okay not if I
misspelled the word fence
oh this this pillar looks interesting
I'm gonna look into that because that
looks very usually useful but we do have
wooden logs MIT and if not logs then we
have because the logs are quite large
but I think yeah you can build it you
can build a fence out of this yeah for
sure
so I'm just gonna build a small fence on
the side of this and hopefully that'll
keep the guests out of the yep yeah this
this look was a great piece as well so
I'm just gonna add this in here make a
quick custom little fence
some people are smiling from outside
yeah so I'm glad for all of the support
that we're getting all right let's see
how this goes
[Music]
can the Tigers climb up wood so it using
be would it be a terrible idea
well here's an idea what if we moved it
again oh very good points well which
animals have escaped this time around
it's the lemurs it's always there's 30
animals that have escaped but you can't
really see whichever scale we're just
gonna ignore those so I do want it to
what extent you can make things
unclaimed above yourself so I'm gonna
put some logs on this side of the wall
to make sure that if they want to climb
they're going to reach an obstacle here
and probably not be able to continue any
further we also have different log
pieces are quite large but these are
really good to place down into the
ground that's actually something that I
want to try later on and then there's a
post as well I could probably use as
support for this do I want to or one
it's probably - should be good so just
real quick post underneath this support
this
and then this is going to be a bit of a
time-consuming job but I want to copy
this around see if the 3d gizmo works
quite well with the self-made thesis
yeah there we go
and that's alright and now I'm just
going to want to connect all these
pieces together until they form coherent
oh I messed up a bit on the placement of
the wooden posts on top of the fence
actually so I'm going to need to read
adjust all these a bit but I think on
the whole that makes sense
yeah red pandas definitely don't look
like giant pandas
I can actually keep some of these traits
probably maybe it's just me but I have
to say and I'm not just saying this for
the sake of saying this but I have to
say this feels bit smoother then it
doesn't planet coaster but maybe it's
just that my own PC has really bad
performance
you mean the building itself no just
moving stuff around with yes what I
build is not intended to be built in an
alpha yeah I mean building and a lot of
them glass as well which I remember they
were quite concerned about with planet
coaster yeah I think in the end that's
actually fine I'll obey please put
everything in what you two have taken
with the screenshots we want to see that
because we'll just see how embarrassed
we look on this tree yeah
yeah and I'm sorry if this is a bit
boring but really that's what building
is like this is why normally my videos
are in time-lapse formats so I can
really concentrate think about what I
want to build and then in hindsight
comments on what I've done so as you can
see the terraforming is actually very
edgy and a bit jank but that's really
just what happens right around paths if
you smooth or move the terrain around a
lot so if I wanted this terraforming to
be the focus of the exhibit I would have
really just smooth that out although now
I do need to think about what I'm gonna
do with this I'm probably just gonna put
a lot of bushes in there or something to
hide the transition I could have
probably put the piece next to the fence
but I forgot about that so that's my bad
actually
actually come to think of that I do want
to remove some of these and put in a
little way maybe I should remove all of
them just do it like so and then add a
small elevated part people wanted me to
show the elevated paths anyway so it'll
be a good thing to show that off all
terrain is too uneven for path it says
what you could do
control connect it like just go to the
website try to connect again no it
doesn't actually you're right but then
I'll still be difficult to connect this
[Applause]
I don't think we'll be able to do that
oh and actually it's my look at those
look at those pillars wow those are new
that's a little good yeah no actually
that was that's what the question was
about people were wondering whether all
the paths they don't have the same
concrete pillars as in planet goes to
because people got a bit tired of those
to be honest but yeah these these look
really nice yeah maybe but even then
that would be quite difficult yeah I
wonder if I can witch over here yeah but
then it's gonna yeah I think it's I I'm
not sure whether that's gonna work
because I think the problem is the
switch it's the switch to the yeah so
actually yeah I'm rather I would rather
want to have this this lookout and since
it's a bit more difficult to build a
raised path I'm just gonna build this
raised first and then I'll come back and
at the more intersection later oh this
is snapping to something back no idea
what it's nothing too
maybe it is
oh that's again it's snapping to the
barriers of the enclosure that makes
sense yeah I think so
and in my case it also doesn't want to
go through the barriers here actually
that's the issue there's a barrier of
course so I can't have the pot going
into the middle of this because there's
a barrier I would need a big gate for
that I think yeah let's see yeah yeah
that's that I think the problem I think
it's too close to the barrier and they
don't know that actually makes a lot of
sense okay so I'm just gonna forget that
I ever wanted to try this I'm just gonna
keep the wall like this so I'm gonna
keep on building this will just keep the
one like this and I'll fill in the gaps
probably with some shrubbery or
something like that to make it a little
bit better I'm sure there might be some
ways to have parts overhang in tea and
exhibits I think I've seen me again this
is my first time trying something even
like this and I don't know to what
extent frontier wants us to do this say
we're trying to just break the game here
and see what the creative elements are
yeah yeah I think I think it was a bit
too low maybe because I didn't man I
didn't notice that like if I went higher
yeah I could place the path above the
barriers so how exactly do this
something to look into later you could
always just make it out of scenery but
then against won't be able to
it looks decent from this item this is
not really to balanced yeah I'm just
gonna have to cover it with some scrubs
at some point alright so I think I want
to start working on yeah I don't know
I'm just gonna build a little bit of the
habitat already oh that's a good point
yeah but I think I'm first gonna build
the building because I don't know to
what extent that's gonna be in the way
of things but a Bengal tiger definitely
needs some sort of a jungle ish biome
so I'm trying to go for well just adding
some of the different textures and just
making sure that it's not completely
just grass but an acceleration into the
ground Tech's history if the Sun
actually doesn't mix too well so many
other textures in a way that's actually
really good because you can see that
it's really scattering
yes all right oh we have a guest
aye-aye-aye honestly have no idea
oh hello this is the lady sign to
everybody this is a book isn't it yeah
like that okay I'm still gonna have to
learn how these textures mix well
that's something I'm not entirely sure
of yet all right so I'm building a tiger
exhibit here and my idea was to have
like a ditch like this right next to the
park so that if you're on the path you
only have this very low fence and you
have a good view of the tiger
yeah that's a building copied around
with some water in it and yeah then
we'll have the exhibit here in the
middle and small little hill where they
could sit on and where we could like
show it and I want to try something in
the back try building a building where
they can relax and be away from the
guests and also whether the staff can do
that
this is actually an electric but I have
to say I've just been building stuff and
really and I have just been exploring a
lot of the building elements in the game
so this is not going to be a very fond
space it's reinforcing but so my idea
was do you know the Hanging Gardens of
Babylon it's this ancient structure
which has yes it's sort of it's not that
the gardens are not really hanging but
it's a building with a lot of trees on
and they call them the Hanging Gardens
because you get all of these vines and
flowers and trees overhanging this
building and I think would be cool to
build a small building like that here
with all of this foliage on it which
will make for the the very jungle
looking environments that the Bengal
tigers live in so yeah that was my idea
I have no idea how well it's going to
work thank you oh yeah that's a really
good point
I think we have some large logs and
definitely one log piece that you can
scatter around
it's insane I am extremely sweaty yeah
somebody just knocked something we know
so I don't know if you guys could hear
it yep bow is a hero out there and
stopping all of those people actually
you don't you don't want to have a Matt
bow after you
not just some work work around here I've
no idea exactly how this should look if
they're and yeah the a bow is definitely
being our bodyguard here you know what
I'm s but yeah if anybody has any ideas
just keep throwing them in the chance
[Music]
Oh actually I just found out that
revenue is going to stream less than
wait is he streaming in this booth right
that would be really cool I'd actually
be down to doing that I've no idea how
many people like it I mean people always
wanted to hear me speak Dutch and I
refused to do it but if it's on your
channel then sure
sorry I'm just crawling through every
single tree in the game because I just
want to have an idea of what's here what
would look best I'm trying to look for
something that would look nice but also
doesn't obscure the back of the
enclosure and also you want to have
trees yeah those are really nice you
want to have trees that could
realistically fit in the climate that
the park is in twice but yep yep yeah
but it's like I've selected the
rainforest biome but I don't add trees
that like would never survive in the
English climate that this park is in
kind of want to find a balance there I
think
your voice sounds the same as the
cautious voice
all right sure maybe it's just the fact
that they're both is actually okay
[Music]
God I've already lost that's a good
point
I think though that oh yeah this is the
one that I want that definitely did help
but yeah actually when I put it on post
it runs much better so I'm gonna keep
that I have one tiger actually at the
moment in the trading center so I think
we should be fine in that regard
I'm sorry
God there are too many questions could
you keep track of the chat please that's
a good start I think maybe a few palm
trees just to set the mood 25 minutes
before my English green sides that's
really fun really like it that was your
time
I'm like again yeah
all right yeah so the Swiss cheese plant
looks like a monster oh and is that just
me because I've never heard that name
before but yeah all of the other bushes
and shrubs are absolutely amazing I am
gonna add some more temperate shrubs in
here just for the ground shrubbery
because there's a lot more in there and
I think there'll be a good way to finish
up this habitat others
there's too much shrubbery I'd hate it I
know I was always complaining that
there's not enough and planet coaster
but this is gonna take ages to know
exactly what everything looks like yeah
yeah I still have an hour
yeah these computers are still on
English time I love this little thing
you could just really fit that anywhere
I know everything that's Chris Sawyer
right in front of us not the Chris
Sawyer
you always have to explain this but he's
also an ambassador and he's helping out
everybody here who's playing the demo on
the demo pieces yeah
[Music]
like everyday yeah and they start like
really early in the morning till 8 p.m.
it's so exhausting I have so much
respect for those guys and you can find
them on the forums as well
I love the I love this poplar tree as
well all right I need to stop gushing
about shrubbery and just lay stuff and
don't have too much power over you at
some point I do when I start handing
little elements into the enclosure but
for now
yeah I'm just stressing up a little bit
of it just to make sure that it's
finished so if the building turns out to
be really difficult and have to spend a
lot of time on it at least the rest is
already done so I don't have to fill my
mission
also a really good point yes yeah or
yeah because they could actually find
I'm just going to put the trees on the
other side of the fence mostly nice box
and again anyway I'm gonna leave that
like that for now and we'll see if they
can use it to escape and if they can
then so be it extra food for the Tigers
but I might look into that later
for now though we're on such a limited
time schedule I do want to try and get
as much done as possible so sorry oh
yeah but there's still a lot to do as
well so am i honestly I have no idea
this might end up really bad I don't
know if bull rush reads also appear in
the region when anytime
but I like these a lot so yeah I mean
honestly same for me as well I don't
know
I barely know any of the foliage options
that they've given us this is so much
I'm not too much of a gardening I might
need to have a consultation set session
with n7 about this and also yeah I like
that we have here the Japanese maple
could build a Japanese gone in with that
and also just lots of autumn trees so if
you want to build a park yeah yep we
have the Japanese maple which looks
[Music]
I really hope oh yeah yeah so oh yeah or
webcam is still there all right
I was about to move the webcam out of
the way yeah yeah there you go yeah
Asia Yeah right yep
but yeah there's so much information
then it takes a while to get used to
exactly where you can find everything
but it's really good that you can find
it somewhere actually I want to place a
few more beads on the other side and
then I want to call it and then I want
to move over yeah maybe
probably the thing is I'm also waiting
for the Tigers actually be in the
habitat so I can actually tell what
exactly their needs are all right
there's so much to do
you're right I want to see what I can do
with this building I'm not entirely sure
how well it's gonna work out 40
computers we played on those two and
there you have way more options for
fencing and its really good so if you
want to see how that works you can check
out 40 right
[Music]
yeah if I had the opportunity to I would
have just erased these fences make them
tall enough for the Tigers not to be
able to climb over them using the trees
but yeah that's something there I don't
think I'll be able to look into with
this bill so this is going to be really
difficult because it will be kind of a
stepwise building but I hope yeah yeah
it'll be like a temple kind of building
yeah I really my inspiration is this zoo
in Belgium I don't know if you've heard
of it it's called fighting geyser yeah I
heard some of the people from a discord
actually wanted to go there at some
point yeah yeah actually I really want
to go there as well yeah yeah yeah
hopefully if all goes well my parents
will be taking me there and some
personal drivers but yeah it's a really
cool zoo what I like about it is well
generally it's not really known as one
of the best zoos because the the the
focus isn't just on the animals like
it's really they want to focus on the
the nature the fauna and the culture of
different parts of the world so in the
Chinese yeah the Chinese themed area for
instance the animals are located in
Chinese gardens and they'll have all
kinds of Chinese temples around it as
well there are some really beautiful
buildings and landscapes in that Park
that's something that I definitely want
to try yeah so something like the
Hanging Gardens just because my idea was
basically I've never actually done
anything like it
raising defense pillar before placing
the pencil that's a really good point
yeah try that later then where are you
guys reading from from the yep
yeah oh well I'm not gonna get too hung
up on the details yeah and some foliage
because yeah the idea for this was also
really oh yeah right and I've snapping
turn on I'm not used to that position it
enough the idea for this bill in general
was we don't have too many pieces and I
want to build something that is from the
region that these animals are from Mike
Riley dies or does and now this isn't
entirely on point because the Hanging
Gardens of Babylon are actually in Iraq
or at least modern-day Iraq but I think
it's a it's a it's a theme that's easily
doable with the pieces that we have in
game plus the foliage in the game is
absolutely amazing and those hanging
gardens are beautiful because there's
foliage overhanging
everywhere so it would be a good reason
to check out all the different foliage
elements and see how they work together
with the building parts
yeah I'm just amazed like how many
things and options are already in this
outfit yeah it is honestly insane
definitely makes sense I'm already
starting to get used to these pieces I
think yeah yeah I think it would
actually be cool to have like a glass
wall at the back of this so from the
train you would be able to look into the
exhibit yeah yeah one sided for sure and
just some here and there I think that
might honestly be cool and I think it
would also just be cool for the train to
go through the building you see that
kind of thing about in Disney parks
where you've got these trains going
around the park and they go through all
the different attraction buildings but
yeah we had some different ideas also
really
about what pieces who could start
combining alright the rent hammer just
passed by and he gestured something at
lady I have no idea what's going on here
exactly but you see what comes out of
that launcher is again I would actually
really like to look into those
centerpieces that's it isn't it oh you
just had to see water that makes sense
that's Bram hammer stealing our our
supply of drinking water yeah yeah yeah
we're all kind of the dying from the
heat right here
climate Savita because they didn't know
what date it would come and I was like
oh my god it's like releasing right
before the planet you mean up I'm like
no I'm not going to be mean up anyways I
want to play 22mm
so now we know today so we my schedule a
new one hopefully you can join us I mean
if you guys are going to play to die so
that would be a much more doable thing
for me since I live yeah well usually
yeah but then for most of the meetup
Selbyville way far away oh you're too
close all right we can look into that
later and then I'll fill in some of
these with walls and some of them I
won't I'm still not entirely sure what
we're gonna do with this all right 45
minutes left it would be cool to have
like a sort of marble staircase here and
I see we don't have pieces for that but
I'm just gonna be cheeky and use this
piece for it
and then we can play some walls about it
I think that's your tour guide all right
[Music]
he'll lower peace in the grounds of the
whole section becomes easily selectable
yeah that's normally what I do if I'm
gonna copy stuff around on a grid that's
actually why you saw me placing those
walls underneath the ground normally I
would go and remove those after the fact
but it's gonna be a lazy bum here who's
cutting all of the corners but yeah I
think so everything in regards to the
building works the same as planet
coasters so if your wait what did I do
wrong there so if you're used to those
then you should be fine I was really
weird
I really don't
yeah I don't think that works I'm pretty
sure that no but there yeah that's also
true isn't it
I know III highly doubt it I I think
even in roller coaster contree there was
something that you had to set up quite
well and I don't think you can set that
kind of thing up in this game it's
volumetric as they say right
no that's I wanted if I have any time
left over after this after this I could
look into it oh wow screaming day like
everyone oh yeah Euston you're still
streaming as well right maybe today was
it filming before the five I tried to go
online and in my lunch time I for 15
points
so actually just to come back through
one of the comments here I'm doing all
of this on the assumption that the
animals will be able to climb this and
that the Tigers will be able to climb
these stairs of the log into the the
building which I'm pretty sure they were
all yet and this will just be there and
their shelter basically it's a bit it's
a bit much isn't it but I just wanted to
expect the footage after the entire
building is done I think and then it
should be looking fine pretty sure I
heard some streamer made like a
rape-murder would like some logs going
from one side to the other as in a
bridge he was like
that's really cool so I'm pretty sure
they will be able to use this too they
can also build exactly so we also played
around with these trims a bit and
they're really cool because you can
really add a lot of variation you can
basically just build them into each
other the way that you want yourself and
there's really a lot of things that you
could do with this different so I like
it instead of adding a single corner
space they've just added a bunch of
different scenery pieces that you can
steal into each other just like that
it's really cool and then we have this
piece which is actually not on the grid
and you can just rotate and move that
yourself and whatever way you want so
I'm just gonna place that over here put
it on the outside so that's going to be
what the pillars are resting on and
that's how you do build a classic or I
guess write it like this so actually I
think that's super cool
and yeah this is the most ridiculously
luxurious for humans kind of built
building for a shelter ever I know I'm
kind of going over the top of this but
just I'm just trying to test out the
building elements and building pieces at
the same time while building a shelter
and building some kind of a cool setting
now realistically you wanna have some
kind of mulch looking elements on top
here right but we don't really have
anything that looks like much I suppose
here so yeah yeah we do actually a
November looks really great in this game
I really liked it
also this interior with winnin horse
makes no sense but I'm just gonna cheat
on that a little bit so yeah and then
the final floor I'm just gonna copy this
over I think and then build the final
floor slightly lower we're gonna get
some force perspective in here guys
shout out to Disneyland yeah because
this is this is way too big but
something like this should probably work
[Music]
this whole section of the building
[Music]
now we can get rid of basically all of
that and move this wall back so that's
that's pretty easy beautiful this is all
just planet coasters though when it
comes to building the real difference is
that the animals should be able to
interact with and finally this pillar oh
right there are some looks like I missed
just a few pieces and I just want there
and actually then there's one thing I
forgot but I'll get to that in a second
this durian
some different covers as well let's
simply ease into the roof of this
that looks better doesn't it I'm gonna
move this move down a bit
and finally if all goes well I can
probably move down through the little
parts of this whole structure a little
bit to make it lower than the bolts
actually I think that's closest to being
good already all of this
yes
you could even be 11
yeah it's something like that maybe a
thing
I think that looks good and really I
know it looks me yes pretty much just
the planet Costa tools like I think if
you're used to planet coaster it'll all
be quite intuitive that's all right okay
and just get over to the other side
but yeah this this is definitely not
supposed to be the final look of the
building in general it should really be
made by the cottage that are overhang on
all of these walls and apparently if I
can be so bold and share some weird
facts about life in general the real
Hanging Gardens of Babylon were supposed
to be one of the seven wonders of the
ancient world just like the pyramids and
all kinds of temples by the Greeks etc
but it's the only one that people aren't
sure it exists because there's no record
of it but apparently the idea was that
there was this one king and his wife was
from a hilly tropical area but well the
the hanging gotta belong was in what is
currently Iraq so not quite that hilly
and tropical so the Hanging Gardens were
created to make this sort of hilly
looking landscape that's that reminded
liver Kings wife of these these hilly
tropical landscapes that she saw in the
place where she was from so it's really
cool it's it's a huge building but it
was supposed to look very natural and
organic which we'll get with some of the
photos this place there's still one
thing that actually I
you want to look into I do want to build
some balustrade on this so I recall
where that was it was Apple decorations
like this and
[Music]
like this yeah probably
but it's gonna be awesome especially
when you have to breathe
I think so
I'm really I really I hope that the
Tigers will be able to climb into this
otherwise I mean I might change the
front of this because at the end of the
on the end of the day this is originally
a building meant for humans and we're
trying to make it into an animal shelter
but yeah yeah I really hope so but in
the tiger we've nested it - oh very good
yeah I can actually already I could
actually probably already open the
enclosure with the tiger in here and
just keep building while the Tigers
already here so do that I should
probably add a habitat gate somewhere I
guess over here okay it's bit glitchy
over there so yeah I think this is this
is decently hidden hopefully with this
tree out of the way of it
okay three doesn't want to be moved
actually all right alpha alpha gameplay
something to keep in mind but yeah so
this should actually now it's time to
add all of the stuff that they need so
let's filter reset filters and filter
bunch of species it's the time yet the
Bengal tiger there we go
I know you want to see where we want to
place though I'm just adding a bunch of
stuff no one had too many toys of course
because they don't want to get bored of
the toys that they have we do want to
switch step up as time goes along and I
guess I actually add two of those
different points yeah it automatically
changes the Terrenas moments is really
handy I think that'll do let's all right
like we forgot how this worked exactly
but I should have the Bengal tiger
someone here and then these centers you
put in the habitat here we go alright
[Music]
I actually forgot to check as well yeah
I'm really excited to see how the tiger
is going to interact with the whole
structure it would be so cool to like
build enclosures in general and build
all kinds of structures and see what the
animals do with it
authorities a male now I don't know what
Bengal tigers should be together with a
female in a habitat or different Mills
babies that's true but sometimes well
you never know good always add a
different one but yeah I'm just gonna
start with one Bengal tiger and see how
far like oh yeah oh yeah there you go
I'm very afraid that the tiger will be
able to escape the enclosure but
hopefully they won't okay so the terrain
distribution is they're all brown so it
doesn't matter it's not what that means
because I've always wondered about
yeah yeah so I think because I've seen
the brown ones before and it's never
really been explained yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah it kind of looks like
there are no some guys are doing really
weird stuff yeah oh wow and it tells you
all of the foliage that it has in sight
no I don't think so just but it shows
you all of the different foliage that
you have yeah that is really awesome all
right okay I'll keep checking what we
have I'm actually gonna have to check
yeah most of the notifications should
probably be the lemurs but what happened
here I can't click ah man where's Finn
the one of the ostriches died
like perhaps one of the ostriches passed
away in the mean time because I don't
see anywhere searching the tap doesn't
seem to work yet but no I
oh yeah good points in the trade center
why whatever but yeah most of these most
of these escaped animals are just the
lemurs because they the game things that
they are escaping but trust me there is
no way of getting out of their exhibit
so there's they're definitely still in
there now where's our Tiger hanging out
it's just just chillin oh yeah the
question is if he will be did you put
like the depending already name
oh no good points that's not forgot
that's something I definitely need to do
yeah it's depending again okay I'm just
gonna hell yeah there we go
Wow the hepa type pitting actually snaps
to the building and is actually part of
the building now that's cool
I'm just gonna add a whole heap of
betting it
make it rain and see if echo is in there
that's an interesting point we can try
that but I think a thought is already
going in there and I really wonder what
the social status like okay I never mind
not yet and I thought we could also
simply be looking Oh God I'm still in
fast-forward mode I think you can
actually see that we need more food and
we need more enrichment oh we need food
and Richmonds make sense yeah I really
want to see what they're gonna do food
and Richmond I think the frozen blood
pumpkin should be good oh yeah put it in
here oh where the pumpkin comes out yeah
oh that makes sense where they're gonna
place them all right so wait yeah that
is the piece that they I think that's
just a glitch where because when they're
done eating you only see this little
pedestal
that's Joelle again so yeah I think it
just doesn't
oh well whatever should be good now
where's the tiger now I think the tiger
is I think so God looks so good with the
rain alright guests thoughts now where
is the Bengal tiger um I'm thinking the
same oh there they are
right yeah I think in real life they
definitely do swim as well which is why
I added some water in habitat as well
I'm not entirely sure if they really
needed according to the game but anyway
I do want to change the weather again
because I want to play with that rain
but yeah let's keep let's keep building
because it's not entirely finished yet I
still need to have all of that footage
over it and also do something to cover
up the railroad at the back here
yeah let's see what other pieces do I
want
oh there are so many really good
planters and things like that in here
yeah I would like to add some planters
and things like that on top of these
fences
thanks to this piece
other thing anything else in chat that I
really need to we'll get to that we'll
get to that
hey orders I'm sorry I missed you
yesterday yeah I missed it I just just a
sliver of time just when I entered
Gamescom he sent me a message saying
we're leaving now
play something underneath that but I try
with yeah yeah I do notice that it's
only laggy when I have the game of play
which is why I actually have it on pause
for quite a bit of gone quite a bit of
the time I'm playing so yeah plus this
is a really big part with 3,000 people
in it anything parts in planet coaster
like they generally started lagging
around that time as well and then yeah
then this thank you I don't want into
this and it's an alpha bill so
I should already add some plants in
there before I forget about that let's
see working in here
I do like that the planters are empty
too so you can really add whatever you
want to add it Oh No good points yeah
that's a that's a really good point I
should look into that I'm just gonna
reset the filters for a bit because I
want to find some kind of flour to put
in here
[Music]
I think we've basically seen everything
that's in the game right now yeah
right something like that
I'm just gonna place these everywhere
real simple although I might remove some
of the Carter's on the side I definitely
do want besides it darling a bit
different and then what we'll do with
the top I honestly have no idea but I
think I saw a pediment which is like the
triangular structure around front these
protections over here yeah so I actually
I want to build fence how did you guys
go back we have here
limestone temples
unfortunately it's in a different
building oh yeah you're right I'm just
gonna look for temple pieces oh I've
actually been making things a lot more
complicated for they do have a temple
piece I like that you can I like that
you can add a lot of that yourself as
well how do you behave on the grid huh
and then what I really like about this
as well is that these have no relief on
them but you can add yourself what you
want to add to it I'm actually you know
copies over actually no I'm not going to
do that yeah it's because I want to have
my they caught believe yet there we go
they do have all kinds of different
relief pieces that you can put in the
middle of this
I'm yeah I'm pretty sure you can yeah
I've definitely seen it oh this is a
lion hair this would have been really
cool if this were the lion well I'll
just build something of a weird actually
that
that's not true because they are the
first ones today that are really self
building yep rest up the whole screens
where I like a lot of people just
checking out of the game so that's not
really true well there are a lot of
screens out there that check out the
animals yep so actually I think I took
the wrong piece they also have a smaller
one yeah I like that a bit more so if
that is correct then they probably also
have different sizes for this oh yeah
they do
alright anyway I just wanted to add a
small one like so
the old bard will be the inclusion of
the to follow so you to make sure that
everything like the whole terrain will
be as they want it to be you have to
make sure that every where it's not
really easier thing so you better get
[Music]
still that bone hold them so they have
to I go you can't do it but I think it's
gonna be hard
yeah
all right I think it's it's about time
to add some quality into this thing
because it really needs it yeah all
right so I'm actually going to stay in
the building so hopefully all of the
foliage there yeah who is definitely one
of the things that frontier seems to
have invested in most the Pooh is there
are so many gameplay elements related to
that and it's it's beautifully animated
it rolls off the hill interacts with
weather
it's it's amazing I think I'm just gonna
add a bunch of this Brecon as under
layers you don't really see all of that
wood anymore yeah we don't really have a
grasp piece I think so I'm just gonna do
it this way
and same on the top floor oh [ __ ]
sorry 15:13 that's that's my one f-bomb
that I get in a two hour stream it's
just like a pg-13 movie that's gonna be
my excuse anyway yeah 20 minutes yeah so
that's a bit tight that's actually add
some around the building as well I still
need to fix that
right so I want to add rain forests and
temperate biomes I don't know never
ready but luckily I have these lovely
guys getting me all the time
Oh God photos just boys makes buildings
look so much nicer I I've always I've
said it too many times but whenever you
have you're working on a building and
you're not entirely sure if you'd like
it or just the landscape in general just
keep at it and once you add the trees
around it it'll make a lot of a
difference
yep oh yeah oh it's Rudy yeah
interesting little tidbit something that
I've seen a lot of commute communes in
Brussels do recently is get people free
yeah it's insane isn't it but yeah a lot
of communes in Brussels have recently
started giving people free foliage to
put around their buildings then people
have to install it themselves but the
community will give it to them just to
make the city much more livable and
beautiful slightly smaller a bamboo
because this is really big
oh yeah there we go phantom bamboo I
think that I wasn't even much better
some of these are clipping into each
other I know I'm breaking all of the
foliage rules ever by putting stuff on
top of migratory never do this if you're
watching you must be much more gentle
and placing down foliage but I'm just
trying to figure out yeah yeah I look at
Brussels I know song she started doing
it and now at her Beck is doing an
entirely sure but it's something that
I've seen happen and it's really cool
and I think the Belgian architecture
really lends itself to it as well
oh thank you
they should just carry this computer and
I love many of the new palm trees and I
haven't even had ended the fines yet we
need we need to add the the real you
know Hanging Gardens of Babylon vines of
course yeah yeah I haven't well actually
that's because I've been playing
enforcement for quite a bit because I'm
wiped oh boy yeah I wanted to avoid
falling into catastrophe while I always
building stuff let's have that
it's just infront of this
I love these vines this finds a really
great
let's just let's have some variation to
apply to using yeah it is it is no bueno
ah yes I love those it's all hanging
ones there is so much variation you can
have with these vine textures as well
like much more than you could in it
those do
yeah the fines are really good
even though there's still 2d which I
totally get because this is one of those
pieces where you don't want to fly your
game with it but these just look really
good the texture is so nice
I want you to snap to claiming a lot in
the forums in everywhere that this game
is like very limited and offers not
creativity as planet coaster
I just want to say you need to play that
for ten minutes and you're all gonna
change your minds and that's not just
because we kind of here and doing it
it's really insane yeah you don't even
need to do the soup you can do whatever
you want it's like yeah weather effect
and great stuff
exactly that's why I think even a lot of
a lot of people aren't maybe into Zeus
as much especially from the planets
ghost community if you want to build
I don't know botanical gardens I've seen
people bring that up already or in a
city or whatever I think there might
definitely be some possibilities for
them and we haven't even seen anything
that'll be in the final game so that's
something to keep in mind as well yeah
yeah we've watched a little bit of the
tiger
what have some some shrubs
let alone the weather and stuff you can
just like by far more honestly it might
seem like something very redundant and
very you know minor but the choice of
foliage yes and that's exactly what I
wanted to try with this build here to
see how the foliage looks how it works
[Music]
I've had that with my first stream it's
still really difficult to find it it's a
bit weird yeah I don't know exactly
what's up with that can I just say that
we are done today I would also take off
that work yeah god I have 12 minutes
left all right
that's quite limited
let's get Bo your garden in and show it
let's see the reaction I'm down yeah
what else do I want to do in here and we
do need to fix up the path at some point
as well yeah
but anyways may I just add that I don't
know how you guys but the thing is you
know even the time limitation didn't
take away any of your skill so this is
so good you should too potentially
trying to build that way more often
that's really great thank you but I know
you prefer okay I'm just concerned
because it's quite laggy as you can see
yeah it's really begging now that's
something to keep in mind I think I've
broken the game yeah so there's that is
it maybe if you just close the menu
which it may be fine I thought it's be
honest yeah as you can see the frame
rate has really tanked quite a bit
although it's still it's doable for sure
okay and if you compare it to how I've
been playing planet coaster for a long
time now it's not as bad but there are
definitely some spikes Oh
not yet we should probably try and see
if we can get another tiger in that
would be really cool do we have any
still in here I mean you know yeah let's
see how that is I know it doesn't really
matter too much actually even if I look
away from it or if I look at the end of
the matter
so maybe the computer is also
overheating that's something to keep in
mind it's extremely hot in this place
and that will probably affect I don't
know exactly how they're dealing with
the heat how the PC is cool but I can
definitely see that part of the issue
all right yeah the train going by is
really cool I'm a bit bummed I couldn't
do much with the train I would have
ideally had like a glass wall at the
back of the train and maybe covered the
train a bit have a go through the
building but yeah there's only so much
you can do in two hours of building
stuff yeah what does that mean exactly
I'm just covering up
oh yeah that's a really good point and
then the game is truly chilly - oh we
have the lady for anything nice
yeah this is this is not my best foliage
work don't pay too much attention to
this I'm just trying to quickly cover up
the terraforming I'm still not entirely
sure what we have any game what else do
we have four options here where's my
monster is
yeah if I were him I would probably be
like all right that's nice it is nicer
to let it play yeah yeah we have an
overheated computer that's constantly
running a demo of the game things like
this could yeah I think this is the
lemur I'm just gonna ignore that
honestly just six minutes late let's
let's try putting in some path elements
oh wait then we need to go to
construction right oh yeah and the
lanterns are separate now so they're not
part on its anymore so I'm just gonna
put these benches kind of in the middle
of the path like so the r-tx 2080 TI in
yeah and a nine and nine nine nine
hundred exactly yeah
thirty-two yeah that's not too many
nation you can barely monochrome
oh I'm switching for roof all right yeah
man I'm not gonna get much yeah my sick
lamb other a classic lamb
yeah I think I'm just gonna go through
this again just like that it's possible
but April don't do it very often you the
thing is why would you do it right in
plain gold but fine exhibit it totally
makes sense
oh no no I'm avoiding I'm hunting just
the front of the benches situation it's
not exactly the same but it's a similar
type of language yeah for sure and I
think all these lamps are just related
to the theme of this map because they do
seem like they try to fit the theme as
well I know you know we have seen so
many more already in the trailers right
I would love to see at some point like a
picture station oh you know when you can
print out or whatever oh yeah our is so
cool yeah I just imagine you could do it
like a father you can capture homes if
you just go and take the you know just
take a photo of it take two photos of
yours I don't know I can find them okay
whatever let's change that I don't know
it's maybe just in there
but I wonder why would he take it
because it's not steep or whatever yeah
right
I mean else you could just do a little
bit of terraforming all right
so I'm just gonna put down a quick few
trees but the area around the enclosure
is definitely very unfinished no no no
because then we would have really missed
out I think on the graphics and the
weather updates and everything exactly I
mean you see so much has changed that it
basically really is from its core a
different game
it just looks similar but there is so
much more about this game like that you
know let alone that the waters
volumetric then you have all the terrain
painting now with the purpose it's not
just painting terrain I have a purpose
so it's in the system yeah yeah the
weather is affecting everything as you
have seen in the streams that is like
how good the weather is it's just insane
yes Paula that my in the habitat I made
that the snow is even more on pieces
than more they tilt like that means for
example if you like that
it's like really good yeah and then even
falls down on the ridges of the brakes
of the brick walls which is really cool
I love the Elms there's too many trees
to keep the track of what exactly we
have and when I want to place anyway
let's put some random breaches down
actually I don't know if they look good
I'm just I'm just gonna keep it like
that the whole surrounding is a bit
unfinished
anyway let's let's quickly look into the
enclosure and see how the tiger is doing
in their habitat where are they oh yeah
good points but it is interesting that
they're not going inside the building
yet they were actually they completely
ignored the rain they were just eating
and they just kept going and snow oh
yeah let's let's try snow and one last
time um yeah we don't have any training
here alright let's let's make it snow
it's gonna take it can for somebody here
that would be cool to check out see how
it look what it looks like from a guy's
perspective what can we find that again
I'll just dig up oh maybe just keep on
one cast you know it definitely doesn't
work on casts I've already oh yeah I
should say you are now going to be
called Tiger pen I'm sorry sir all right
I actually didn't I'm gonna do that in
the meter
oh wow it looks really cool and with
this no no the way that it falls on all
of the foliage is insane yeah yeah isn't
that insane that's really insane yeah
let's reset the filters put a small
heater inside here
actually it's already warmer inside
because of the bedding in snow it's like
that this is cool you have a system
actually already know it's this without
having a heater that's so good oh now I
lost my tacit cam where's my tacit can I
help my people get their umbrellas out
for this as well that's pretty cool all
right sir
I'm sorry Scott Scotty Scotty where's my
there we go oh I need to get out of here
we need to get out of here well we can't
because I just I closed it officer went
with the door can we go through the door
Aztecas can that is a good question of
this for frame rate reasons I am gonna
pause the game here for a sec oh yeah we
can help awesome so there's the
enclosures I'm gonna switch the weather
sex
settings because I do want to see in
normal conditions as well and let's have
that playing
yeah from this angle I think it's quite
good
so yeah that's the lion enclosure tiger
why do I keep doing
yep all right I don't have too much oh
yeah and it's six perfect so six oh yeah
god what is it
actually it's it's yeah anyway guys
thank you so much for watching
it's been amazing I've had a lot of fun
in the stream two hours has been just
enough time to actually do something
really cool in the game so I'm really
happy about that as well it's really
afraid that it would not be quite enough
to build a full enclosure but yeah I'm
happy with it and I like to thank you
guys as well for a comment to my stream
being here with me suffering along with
me in this extreme heat like words
cannot describe how warm it is in this
room right now might be God but yeah
it's been amazing I really love it and
shout out to n7 for always giving the
best little tutorials and foliage and
planet coaster without him I don't think
I would have been able to do this and
also this I think Renton hammer is going
to stream in here is already complaining
right in front of us on Twitch so yeah
you can follow him over there as well
that's Ari and B H Amer and yeah yeah he
might but I don't know if he wants to
get this leg
anyway yeah thanks so much for watching
guys hope you guys all have a good day
and I'll see you sometime in the future
I have no idea exactly when but this has
been my last three readings you'll also
be able to see the ladies liners they'll
actually she'll be streaming in touch I
agree and I might drop by there if you
want to see me speak but exactly yeah
thanks for watching everybody
you
you